foreign
[Music]
well hello dear friends Welcome to our
favorite program here at Secrets
unsealed I'd like to know this is a
question and answer program where you
send us the questions we do research and
we attempt to answer the questions based
on the evidence
we're very pleased that you decided to
join us today for the program this takes
place once a week it's only a half an
hour program we've thought about in the
future expanding it because we have a
huge pile of questions
we want to encourage you to continue
sending the questions if they're not
answered immediately well be patient
because we have a big pile of questions
that have come in and we answer them in
the order in which they come I want to
give you the address where you can send
us your questions you'll see it on the
screen TV at some tv.org once again TV
at
suntv.org I'm here in the company of
Pastor Daniel Miranda who uh for over a
year worked full-time at Secrets
unsealed now he's the associate pastor
of Fresno Central Church and also he's
ours he comes and helps us with I'd like
to know and he also helps us with
sermons as well as symposiums and other
programming and we really appreciate him
doing double duty he's young and
energetic he's not going up in years
like me so uh we are very thankful that
he's able to do double duty Fresno
Central as well as what he does here at
uh Secrets unsealed and uh we're very
glad that you're with us thank you
Pastor Roy it's good to be here with you
as well and this wonderful program
praise the Lord and we want you to have
a word of prayer to start okay let's
pray
Heavenly Father return heaven we thank
you very much for
this new program of I'd like to know
that we can have again as we prepare
ourselves to open your word we want to
ask for a special blessing and
outpouring of the holy spirit in our
minds
we understand that it is a solemn duty
to open your word before others
especially in programs like these when
the videos can go viral we want to stick
to what is written so give us this
sermon and uh
respect for your word
for not going or not going against or
beyond what the Bible says we pray all
this in the name of Jesus amen amen well
in our last program
we formulated a question and we ran out
of time so we want to come back to that
question now and basically
this question comes from Malawi Africa
and after quoting the fourth Commandment
Exodus 20 verses 9 through 11. we
actually 8 through 11 the person
mentions this due to the mode of
payments we have in these last days and
puts in parentheses technology doesn't
make sense to refrain from buying
anything on the holy day except buying
electricity units or mobile phone units
on the Sabbath in other words does
modern technology
annul the idea of buying and selling on
the Sabbath the the basic gist of the
question well okay so good question very
good question
let us go to the book of Nehemiah I
think in Nehemiah 13 we find a good
principle that will help us answer this
question Nehemiah 13 this chapter
Nehemiah comes back this is the second
period of his governance and when he
comes back he realizes that there are
some things that need to be corrected he
starts making some reforms among the
reforms that he makes is the Sabbath
reform
let's read about that in verse 15 and
onward in those days I saw people in
Judah treading wine presses on the
Sabbath and bringing in sheaves and
loading donkeys with wine grapes figs
and all kinds of burdens which they
brought into Jerusalem on the Sabbath
day and I warned them about the day on
which they were selling provisions
men of tire dwelled there also who
brought in fish and all kinds of goods
and sold them on the Sabbath to the
children of Judah and in Jerusalem then
I contended with the novels of Judah and
said to them what evil thing is this
that you do
by which you profane the Sabbath day
did not your father's dudas and did not
our God bring all this disaster on us
and on this city
yet you bring added wrath on Israel by
profaning the Sabbath
so it was at the Gates of Jerusalem as
it began to be dark before the Sabbath
that I commanded the gates to be shut
and church that they must not be opened
till after the Sabbath then I posted
some of my servants at the gates so that
no burdens would be brought in on the
Sabbath day now the merchants and
sellers of all kinds of Wares Lodge
outside Jerusalem once or twice
then I warned them and said to them why
do you spend the night around the wall
if you do so again I will lay hands on
you from that time on they came no more
on this side so it's talking about
commercial Enterprises on the Sabbath
that's right but does that apply to
modern technology where you can just you
know tap your phone and pay something by
PayPal
well the principle here
is not so much the amount of work but
the nature of the activity which is
secular commercial and that's what God
wants us to avoid on the Sabbath day uh
for me I don't see the difference even
though electronically is faster but it's
still commercial activity
that can really distract us or make us
lose the reverence for the holy day yeah
and I
and it's passage that you read makes it
clear you know sometimes we try to
rationalize we say well modern
technology uh has made it uh you know
made a lot of the Bible prescriptions
obsolete but that's not the case the
principle is that on Sabbath we're not
supposed to buy or sell because that's a
secular activity now if there's an
emergency you have to go to the pharmacy
to buy medicine for someone that's a
different story but you know doing your
own commercial Enterprises it says we're
supposed to take away our foot from
doing our will on the Sabbath day now
someone would say this is not in the
question but someone would say okay how
about when I write checks to for my
tithing on the Sabbath or or today the
church has the online giving and some
people just you know do it
electronically send their tithes and
offerings
um
wouldn't that be the same just a
question that comes to my mind
um well
I can only speak from my experience
I never write my check for tithes and
offerings on Sabbath mornings right I do
it the the during the week before and
that there is an inspired Council on
that yes there is absolutely in First
Corinthians 16 yes and maybe we should
read that yeah it's used to try and
prove that we're supposed to keep Sunday
as a day of worship exactly but it's
really teaching good stewardship
uh yeah First Corinthians 16 I think
it's one and two one and two yes
so you might want to read that if you
get it before me
one and two says now concerning the
collection for the Saints as I have
given orders to the churches of galatia
so you must do also on the first day of
the week let each one of you lay
something aside storing up as he may
Prosper that there be no collections
when I come
so Ellen White comments on this and she
says speaking of tithing and offering
that we need to set apart our Tides
first before anything else and of course
that happens during the week right and
then and then she says on Sabbath we
should return it there's a specific date
to return it but we should set it apart
before and I would say if you do it
online you should do the same thing yes
absolutely you know and it's it's a lot
quicker to do now you know like if
you're going to send it directly to the
conference just take a few seconds yes
you know if if you write out a check
it's going to take longer but I think
that uh you know the the principle
applies even in the case of modern
technology
okay now we have another question uh
this is regarding the year 27 A.D
and it says hi as an Adventist I have
known from my youth days that 27 A.D is
the year Jesus was baptized
this is based on Luke 3 which says that
during the 15 years the 15th year of
Tiberius Caesar Jesus was baptized
however when I went to the internet to
Tiberius it says that he started ruling
from 14 A.D if you add 15 years to 14
A.D we arrive at 29 A.D
so what can we say about the year 31.
27.
yeah 27 and of course I said it would
impact 31. oh okay uh and it would
impact 34. right as well but it's
dealing specifically with 27. correct
correct yes
um
if I remember well
the way that look is counting chronology
here
he's using non-essential years
and um
he was he was
um he started reigning in this year I
think in the month of August
corresponding to our time
so they were they considered that at the
the the the the political the Civil year
began in the fall so there was the last
days of of um
of of this year 8014 and that remaining
those few weeks of that year which he
reigned are considered like the first
year and then you have
beginning in September or the fall
tishri then you begin you have the
beginning of the second year so actually
in 80 14 we already have two years
yes uh it's called inclusive inclusive
Reckoning yes and you know it was very
common and it all depends what culture
you're dealing with from Antiquity uh
some use accession years as a full year
and some didn't but in this case I think
that the solution to this problem is as
you have suggested that the accession
year is counted as one year that's one
year as well as the next year which was
a full year
so by the way there's an excellent
article on this that was written by
Gerard domsteekt and I have a copy of
that article and I think that if the
person who asked the question uh wishes
I'll try and track it down and send a
copy of that excellent article that
proves the year uh 15 of Tiberius Caesar
and the year 27 as the year of the
baptism of Christ
so very good I I'm not promising this to
everyone who's watching the program
I'm promising it to the individual who
actually asked the program the the
question
all right let's go to the next question
which is uh very interesting
in the book Patriarchs and Prophets page
36.
paragraph five
Ellen White States and he quotes Christ
was still to exercise divine power in
the creation of the earth and its
inhabitants
in first John 1 5 the Bible declares
this is the message we have heard from
him and declare to you God is light in
him there is no Darkness at all so could
Darkness mentioned in Genesis 1 verse 2
be an indication of the creation or
organization of the Earth
after Satan's rebellion in heaven found
in Revelation 12 7-9
I am looking at a Biblical verse
attesting the creation of the earth
after Satan's rebellion in heaven
thankfully uh
I think that PR means Pastor Freddie
from French Polynesia Pastor Freddie
he's writing
to us from from French Polynesia French
Polynesia right
um so it's Pastor Freddie it's Pastor
Freddie from French Polynesia yeah uh so
I think the basic question is uh did was
this earth created before or after the
fall of Lucifer
uh and I have a quotation here which I'm
sure that you're very well acquainted
with as well that shows that really this
Earth was created after the rebellion of
Lucifer correct uh in early writing
space uh 145 I'm going to read the
statement do you have that statement
there I don't have it here okay I'll
read it
Satan was once an honored angel in
heaven
next to Christ
his countenance like those of other
Angels was mild and expressive of
Happiness his forehead was high and
Broad showing great intelligence his
form was perfect his bearing Noble and
Majestic
but
when God said to his son
let us make man in our image so they
hadn't done it yet let us make man in
our image Satan was jealous of Jesus so
that's where sin begins when God spoke
the father spoke to the son about
creation so the world had not been
created yet
he wished to be consulted concerning the
formation of man and because he was not
he was filled with Envy jealousy and
hatred he desired to receive the highest
honors in heaven next to God and
Patriots and Prophets the first couple
of pages described a Heavenly Council
that was held where the father called
all of the hosts of Heaven together to
explain the position of his son and
Ellen White says that that Christ was
still to create this Earth in Adam and
Eve so I believe that clearly according
to the spirit of Prophecy
Satan's Rebellion took place in heaven
before the creation of this world
exactly and that has of course biblical
support because when God first creates
man and we and the man and the woman he
warns them against eating from The
Forbidden tree well the problem is so
first of all if he warns them is because
there was already a conflict going on
and the problem was so not so much the
truth 3
but the being that was in the tree
because Satan was limited to the
Forbidden tree so God's main concern was
that Adam and Eve would have
closeness yeah to Satan on that tree and
Ellen White actually in patriotism
prophets she says that that the reason
why Satan took the appearance of a
serpent is because Adam and Eve had
already been warned yes against a fallen
angel that I rebelled in heaven yeah and
that would explain
uh the reason why in Revelation chapter
the serpent is called the ancient
serpent so the serpent that was in the
tree
was actually uh Satan using the serpent
yes as a medium yes which shows that he
had fallen
before
Eve came to the tree right so it's it's
definitely biblical
oh yes now I want to also comment on a
portion of the question by Pastor
Freddie where he says that
Satan's rebellion in heaven found in
Revelation 12 verses 7 through 9. well I
it is my personal conviction
that actually this war in heaven even
though in evangelism we use it a lot for
when Satan rebelled in heaven and I
don't see any problem with that but a
careful study of Revelation 12 this
specific verses actually are talking
about Satan's uh when he was defeated at
the cross yes what we see the verses
where I see
Satan's rebellion in heaven when he was
expelled he's in the first verses I
think three to five when it says the
tale drew the stars from heaven and cast
them to the Earth right so that's where
I see it yeah I don't know if you agree
with me I agree with you 100 and that's
what I've taught here at Secrets
unsealed but he's still called the
ancient Circus
the kind of a flashback to the Garden of
Eden that's right so so I think that the
Bible is very very clear that the fall
of Lucifer in heaven took place before
creation
and uh you know the the evidence of what
you say if I could just follow up on on
what you mentioned about these verses
dealing with the defeat of Satan of the
Cross another verse that is similar to
this is Jesus says I saw Satan fall like
lightning from heaven and Ella white
makes it clear that this is talking
about not the original casting out of
Satan but the casting out of Satan at
the cross right and when you read the
next verses after it says in verse 9 so
the Great Dragon was cast out that
Serpent of old called the devil and
Satan who deceives the whole world well
he's been deceiving the whole world
when he's cast out according to this
exactly so it's not the original casting
out because there was no world to
deceive and then it continues saying who
deceives the whole world he was cast out
and his angels were cast out with him
and then verse 10 then I heard a loud
voice saying in heaven this is as a
result of him being cast out uh now
salvation and strengthened the kingdom
of our God and the power of His Christ
have come for the accuser of our
Brethren who accused them before God day
and night there was no one to accuse
back then he was already accusing when
he was expelled he had been accusing
them for a period of time who accused
them before God day and night and and
then it says and they overcame him by
the blood of lamb and the word of their
testimony which could not be true
originally of Adam and Eve it's dealing
with his deceit of the whole world yes
so clearly the context indicates that
the primary meaning is uh to casting out
the cross although there is an
indication by the expression ancient
serpent and that this is the same
serpent that led the world into sin
exactly yeah yeah so very good
okay
um
here's another question
why are our churches changing into
worship center and preaching the
prosperity messages
is this according to any of our message
so the question primarily has to do with
preaching a Prosperity message why is
there so much Prosperity preaching in
the Adventist Church now that's the gist
of the question
well I cannot answer for every
individual Pastor or preacher that might
be preaching a Prosperity message
but definitely as a church officially we
we do not support this tendency but it
is already a reality that in some
Churches this tendency is present
when we look at Jesus Jesus never
preached a Prosperity message actually
he preached about the cross
in the sermon on John 6 is a long sermon
so we don't have time to quote it but he
was so straightforward that even some of
the big crowd that followed him they no
longer followed him after that
Jesus continually presented the cost of
following him he presented the cross and
let me read
um one text I think this is Matthew 16.
this is the gist and the essence of
Jesus's message Jesus is preaching
um Matthew 16
verse 24
and
20 through 26 then Jesus said to his
disciples if anyone desires to come
after me let him deny himself and take
up his cross and followed me and follow
me for whoever desires to save his life
will lose it but whoever loses his life
for my name will find it for what
prophet is it to a man if he gains the
whole world and loses his own soul or
what will a man give in exchange
for his soul
yeah you know G s had more to say about
money
than any other topic yes
and in most of his comments regarding
money
he's saying that
uh True Believers should be investing
their money in blessing others amen uh
you know unfortunately those people in
John chapter 6.
who in times of prosperity when there
were Loaves and Fishes you know they
multitudes followed Jesus but then when
he started preaching I'm the bread of
life I'm the bread of life you know you
have to eat my flesh and drink my blood
which is talking about assimilating
Christ to the word uh they followed him
no more because they said there's no
financial gain in this for us and that's
the reason why Judas went and committed
suicide because he finally said you know
there's no Financial benefit in
following Jesus I thought that maybe we
could get him you know to deliver
himself and and destroy the Romans and
then become king and we become very very
prosperous right unfortunately the
people in John chapter 6 list listen to
a particular radio station w-i-i-f-m
I know there was no radio back then by
the way right you know what Wii FM is no
please don't what's in it for me wow
so many people follow Jesus for what's
in in it for me I think that they're
after the fish at the bread and not
after Jesus right after the material the
materials yes and and it's interesting
you know if there are preachers in the
Adventist Church that are preaching a
Prosperity message uh why are they
preaching that message because they're
getting it from the gospels no they're
actually copying what is done in the
great mega churches of the world today
where it's constantly you know plant a
seed plant a seed which means give us
donations yes and the Lord is going to
bless you the Lord is going to make you
prosperous you're going to get rich
well that's totally opposite of what
Jesus taught about what we should do
with the resources that God has given us
amen and with this we don't mean to say
that then true Christianity means to be
in poverty we're not trying to suggest
that of course not because Jesus didn't
didn't condemn riches in themselves he
condemned the love of riches yeah not
only Jesus but the entire Bible so we're
not saying this here but what what we're
saying yes God bless blesses there's
some blessings in accepting Jesus Christ
but that shouldn't be the focus of our
Center even those who are blessed more
God requires more of them so even in
that there is a cross to bear so the
discipleship the Jesus what Jesus called
well the way he calls us to follow him
is a really narrow way yes that's right
um you know one of one of the richest
men mentioned in the Bible is job
what did job do with his riches he was
very rich he was yes but but in job 29
job explained what he did with by the
way we talk about Abraham too many rich
people in the Bible use their resources
to bless others amen not to accumulate
greatness for themselves Amen in Job
chapter 29 and uh beginning with verse
um let's see here
verse
10.
the voice of nobles was asked and their
tongue stuck to the roof of their mouth
when the ear heard then it blessed me
and when the I saw then it approved me
and now it says about what job did with
his resources because I delivered the
poor Who Cried Out the fatherless and
the one who had no helper the blessing
of a perishing Man Came Upon me and I
caused the Widow's heart to sing for Joy
I put on righteousness and it had and it
clothed me my Justice was like a robe
and a turban I was eyes to the blind I
was feet to the lame I was a father to
the poor and I searched out the case
that I did not know I broke the fangs of
the wicked and plucked the victim from
his teeth
so job lived a life of service to others
with with his riches he met the needs of
people amen amen and there is a place
for people like job in our church
that God blesses them more so that they
can be a blessing to those who are in
need give and and it shall be given unto
you amen we make money by investing
money that's right in in in the needs of
others that's God's economy yes that's
right economy of this world is safe for
yourself invest on yourself yes God's
economy is invest in me investing others
and I'll bless you more yeah make up
Treasures in Heaven amen well time is
just about up uh we need to end the
program yes thank you for watching us
remember to send your questions to TV at
some
tv.org and we will get your question
soon God bless you
foreign
[Music]